everything you just heard is real like
if you do the push-ups you get the
muscles if you do Facebook reels right
now three a day instead of just doing
Tick Tock and Instagram I promise you
you'll grow much better on Facebook
reels than everywhere else and I don't
care if you're selling to 23 year old
cool kids if you like a video on YouTube
shorts that's like a tick tock or an
Instagram reel you title it based on
what people search your YouTube short
might become a video that leads to a lot
of business opportunities for you just
the YouTube short because unlike tiktok
and Instagram it's not like ephemeral or
it goes away after a day or an hour it's
kind of there because YouTube's the
second biggest search engine if you
start a podcast if you post on LinkedIn
three times a day if you start a
Facebook group if you if you if you my
friends everything you just heard is
real like if you do the push-ups you get
the muscles like I promise you